how do you know that that's your Kink
because I got my ass licked without
asking it happened to me the girlfriend
I was with at the time that was a girl
no no she was like here let me try to
lick your ass and I was like oh she goes
lower and lower past the ball I was like
whoa it was like a nuclear eject button
yeah your legs go up shot like Apollo
11. yeah I never did it one chick it was
like I want to eat butt I dated someone
from the future to each their own the
male orgasms of the prostate yeah
exactly apparently it's a amazing orgasm
right you'll never know never know
that's too far how would we know that we
would like it unless we do you know it
so you're trying to I don't know is it
gay if I'm like maybe I should find out
if it's a female's finger is that still
gay if I cook one time that doesn't make
me a chef that's true from a
dude one time it doesn't mean I'm gay I
sure as not a chef
thank you